clock and portland won it 101
to 99. but this is a portland team as
that three-pointer from
mccullum is good clock
and portland won it 101-99
but this is a portland team as that
three-pointer from
mccullum is good cj working against
davis five seconds left scissor dribble
between his legs
step back three-pointer cj mccollum
don't do it to him that's gonna be mad
at himself cj between the legs crossover
use the screen
column of the line shooting one
game here but yusuf nurkic continues to
impress he's there for all these players
melo
feeds the nerd they're going to go back
out into the post i like this
i like this use of nurkish with the last
word gets the flip shot to fall you see
the blazers bench hollering
back come the blazers you got to go back
to nerc
cj work in the middle nice nice split
little lollipop drops hands it back to
davis and the blazers take back the lead
43-41
ciaco blazers wanted to travel he's
working against zazonia 10 seconds left
on the clock siako
stripped by nerf nerc diving to the
floor
sends it off a wrap gary tran junior
gets the loose ball cj
flips it over to nerd nerc thoughts of a
second three
and yousef nurkic splashes the glass
cj and dame we just need you to be good
for eight
they can do it they can do enough lowry
second excuse me tied for first in the
league with montrez harrell with 30
charges drawn this season yeah
he'll sell it oh nerk bats that one away
he gained the lead they're on a 7-0 run
to start this third quarter
and by the way that last play
as you see cj with the lay
here comes cj cj working against powell
tries to get to the baseline beautiful
pass to mello and
mello elevates for the slam okay watch
him throw this ball with the left hand
throw it out there go get it
you have full control in the whip around
pass
team of 26 from the free-throw line for
the raptors
cj knifed through the raptors defense
that one rolls out but tapped by again
by yusuf nirkman yusuf nurkic
with an early double-double